our teas he looks like he's in it for
the long haul Jeff City infant gets the
crush on two - and there's the sonic
wave - vacuum in it's the Phoenix ult's
is it gonna be enough to turn this fight
but no eg still coming out victorious
arteezy even with just a scratch of
house secures a rampage at 14 minutes
and that's right guys this week on
bestop we're looking at one of the
sickest plays you can pull off in a game
of dota 2 the rampage please email me at
gaben at valve software calm and let me
know about your rampage as you guys know
a rampage requires you to get the
killing blow on every single hero on the
enemy team without your team stealing
those kills dendi kept the tongue so
without further ado guys let's get this
video started with some absolutely sick
rampages they're up against Megas you do
oh thank you miracle he didn't range in
the towel and maybe this rape you can
turn things around in the shallow grave
in satanic there's so much work arcade
get back into our miracle is still
hanging the bloody found it he's still
alive there all of this learner can't do
any more damage miracle again he still
is legacy mortal as well they out pull
printing aligns it off with this rapier
monkey so they come out in the fountain
that is it I thought they smoked for
this maybe not a nurse when you're out
but while they're doing that Bernie's
getting caught in the midlane quickly
dealt with finished off by a night end
beep from fair as rtz will close them
out now the fat connects on several RTC
does gets done burning boat back andrea
gauges 4:30 trying to finish him off as
come no I'm not
tanky an art or unstoppable that invoker
dead for a hundred and burning left to
do it alone the cavity has been ripped
wide open
ohlet's jumped on BKB sub button there's
the song Flynn's no does end up dropping
because of the BKB on the storm and now
he's slept I see yeah they're just gonna
try to leave but they're gonna be caught
off from behind for stuff get sporty
back away London bambo get managed to
get carapace but the Eclipse goes off
and separate put me in some trouble
sight chasing them out of the base bambo
that time stole eclipse and now he's
gonna turn it around double kill for him
chippings is about the drop - he does
make it sexy bamboo you monster now the
decay how goes the tube some Beach just
want to back away that's what I say size
goes in looking for the Kazi doesn't pop
to the time he's surrounded by many they
but beautiful aesthetically caught up
there pulled over the top connects up to
Tyler Joey holding their ground for now
is in the wine chest on the hook he goes
back in but it's too late if that boys
already gotten off the onions and
finished off anyone yet though holding
these back light heels maybe stands and
he looks to turn this has the chance
available but not the vision he needs
every bit of each he getting low aside
for the queen of pain who is the healthy
one that goes in first baby Silas did
they catch him out this will be a huge
takedown he's kept the light glimmered
back in a way but it's getting the kills
and maybe in silence on the run they
have to get like a really clean
initiation on them what they did last
time was swap into an axe call bring
them in the T fours can they do it again
Gigi Schumm he gets a nice he's gonna
try it's gonna run it just walked in
there and grab it
thank you turns back in a way here they
make their eyes
bring us open up let's see if snowball
five-second snowball oh my god this
Husker is just going out of control it's
over and you cancel old five gets the
Pogo straight behind the BJP oh he's
able to take down ace now he's looking
over for more turns to work puppy Reza
gets a double kill he needs to go back
in empathy fly buying time for himself
with the grave upon his dazzle but he's
still full they've lost three the
co-state work the output the study's
findings after but he had the control of
Reza Reza was gone
Oh tree kill for me can I get the
rampage he's looking for work Erikson
yes we can we're gonna try to make the
jump here on to lean up of the swab back
makes tusk and easy killings as well
yeah they're gonna jump further forward
here now huh spies back into the game
swindles is just gonna try and hit away
here but what is he honestly even gonna
do brought down to about half HP that
second beat ball is gonna come through
meatball as rollin still puppy is out
there Oh eternal Envy what a freakin
player Lina has to buy back a second
time now is they're gonna continue to
chase on over here shards go out onto we
but what are you gonna do honestly
chassis is starting to fall now from the
right-click from atrani
magic missiles abound and it looks like
after that triple kill it might just be
bout over swindles jumps back a second
time to swap on the limp he's gonna end
up going down does get the yule scepter
to try and stay alive
Oh a nice snowball save but is it gonna
be enough I am not exactly sure he's on
the low ground back is it really
Oh rampage a turtle Envy she should want
to hit it on it now he's actually gonna
be receiving another gank instead
the team's breath
really worth it as liquids pretty coffee
here they'd better be careful about
gonna be use on clinic not able to get
stuck in the kinetic field as we have a
one-for-one trade into getting a double
kill apparently in the backend and Wow
their dissolute League on Ebola said the
aquatic shield is but good that the Lord
Kaname is cleaning up so hard and an
altar hill for dedicating it a rampage
they're gonna clamp the tuners nemesis
Lex charge on cheeky he's gonna pop his
only little slope coming down his loan
they're gonna have to disengage oh they
were gonna omnis rush that's what great
using the Lotus or PT now hook shot back
in resolution isolated from the team
takes a soul assumption sonic wave
connects on silent again Tanaka's on
silent with the ultra kill Oh back Guapo
from aloha dance and silent Oh any
badges of noises oh they don't buy a
date back into it I think they might be
she's gonna die definitely be ready to
jump
no jumping the rabbit hole two three all
the side place double kill for maybe
they'll get off the black hole is sold
to DDC oh man triple kill us baby
finding a bull paint babies down as well
I'll trick you late to manage to purse
the ages here until five Magnum lgd's
chasing art easy to lonely boy all on
his own here LTE looking to finish these
later they can find it on TV China by
space try to my type of fab Rob page for
baby Empire will back out there a second
haunt aces they really want they said it
could be costly got a reinitiate
get BKB the crane finds it sometime he
gets off the first split the [ __ ]
good nice done that profits coming down
now as well gets taken down pleasure
okay kill my solo holy [ __ ] man Letty
Brent [ __ ] this is broken book he's
doing it guys those were some unreal
rampages but you know the one thing
that's better than a rampage more than
one rampage as you already know every
kill after a rampage multiplies said
rampage so six kills that's a double
rampage seven kills that's a triple
rampage because we all know valve is
really good with numbers
I don't understand
just like three three kills tripled with
three heroes three just give me anything
anything you want say whatever okay I
don't I don't care
you've killed more than two people in
less than four but now they chopped up
they're looking for disrupt up the
forest right from simple create small
space and you have Raven I don't know
how he's face to live through all of
this the photo blogs haven't killed them
off they get the back onto our now
urosepsis it SK taken out of the fight
behind the second but he's no bling
pirates right off right down and he goes
deeper off the wall or comes in the
Armel already has an old truck he'll
make a tower rampage and they can get
more creeper glimpse down again these
limits your vision think the Thunder
strikes
oh no they turn burn will they give him
the double you better tin that is not
yours to have this is not your food
stared at the stubble rampage pariah
this is a fight you know you're gonna
lose if you looked at it yeah you know
you're probably gonna get team eyes
unless but he's not the wise creation
right I know the song anyway he goes dip
in the SP disrupt you two went the same
time it's been initiated solo is at
least isolated here but when the boss
often bara striking for pasta
he calls savage he cornrows and MC a
completely cold pasta will come in that
everything still wasn't even used but no
one's and so much damage to butterfly
hey you I can't even hit him right now
no one is untouchable and you got em SS
trapped on the front lines fibers are
coming in from MP but this feels like
desperation MV blinks forward no one
wait and then two hits down the SD moves
on to ends meet heads our rampage and
Tenant really is the game a UI is trying
to clean everything the only upside is
if I can only a lunar at e8 the downs it
is is the lunar in the TA to be still
alive for photos Pro through a UI tries
to be a man but it's just not manly
enough this is no fun for any vet of
Navi if you're
you be drinkin ever
back outside the tire face he is gonna
give big shot and stuff buddy it's gonna
get swans to test right now and ear is
still looking to the Daedalus the dopey
is flying in their eyes right now and
look at this TF 3 tau of smell bulb bulb
all out OPEC eggs the old Depot started
putting keep me before my safety got a
burrito for now from him
in this case in every corner he got one
good position now each chopped zero
he's already himself adult wrinkles and
he might get fall Rizvan debrief here
and he declares them dead he will
interest him up for the moment the boss
book the became be he was Revenge of
this ball of the liar cricket here up
will now go again Indiana Bob
[Applause]
maybe lips now and now the turn around
are in the fish the zip they're on top
of boat for them chalice he's pumped
somnus he's matched around an F boy does
come in just get the dune down on tag
success as xxs will surely full law by
turning up a look at the speed of this
man it's just forward as well our mate
zipping around oh my gosh Nika picks up
the double gets the triple getting queue
as well that'll be an ultra kill a
buyback is there from a vodka
he's even across the trading notes omnis
is low he wants to try and find it are
they put the beat down though the bluff
right out he looks towards aggressive
getting the bat she's killing off the
spectres breadboards that's the rampage
for AMI
why doesn't the trees give him the
double white and his double rampage
forearm a xx's Chris Bennett whole town
could it be a triple rampage for AMI
all right here comes the potential final
hurrah here for mineski looking for the
jump in there it is around the Prophet
quick blow up and well he made just a
little walk away but now the coils gonna
be snap since they're gonna be just walk
back here doesn't look like yet they
said make their focus here the ck is
able to bust down the dark save a man he
loses his life right after will have a
buyback but seems to be a bit reluctant
on spending it here because there are
troubled us over salted and killed
he'll have to buy that gamma cases I'm
not buying back those three
and everyone else Milan will biovolt oh
man he's just assaulting the rest of the
team rampage for raging potato dive at
our age get in there make it five make
it six go for seven triple rampage
breaking potato it is a good way to go
school okay look at this age do this bro
but it's just not enough when your basis
our jeopardy and cookies coming for this
guy it's going to come on
give me more than they say give me more
that's Caracas a and now it's gonna be
the turnaround story - oh boy oh boy
it's amazing this is being do it do it
crit no not any monetary little oh he's
running in circles he doesn't want to
know the mental side more they say well
guys that's it for best of this week now
he may have noticed over the last few
weeks the gentleman behind me ripping
anime 24/7 well the truth is his name is
Dimitri and he actually hates it and I
force him to watch anime for the
purposes of this video now here's where
you come in I want you to comment below
what anime he needs to watch for next
week's video the one with the highest up
votes you will see and keep it clean
guys this is a family show
see you next week thanks for watching if
you want more great content just like
this be sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]